young people can tell when old people
are texting you know when you text
certain people you can tell whether they
read your text yes so if you're young
you leave that feature off but old
people don't even know to turn that off
so that's a but I am texting like a
young person now young people don't use
periods anymore in their texting and
they don't use capital letters they even
will just run on sentences they do not
really use periods a period indicates
that you're really angry like if you
wrote me yeah you see these are things
you don't know that's what I'm telling
you because you're where you go to get
this information you go to our staff
some of the young women on our staff
know these things I evidently like
grammar is for the elderly and uh I love
gramar I think it you know sometimes you
read something that doesn't make any
sense because of grammar you're there
you're old oh yeah sadly you don't look
old but you're old uh you really don't
look old by the way you really do have a
youthful look but um like for example do
you leave
voicemails sometimes I know you voice
yeah that means you're old like you're
not supposed to leave voicemail do you
cold call people meaning do you just
pick up the phone and call someone to
have a conversation no then you're being
youthful because appointment yeah yeah
you should write first hey you got are
you free right I like to talk to people
on the phone rather than text I can't
stand texting I [__] hate it I got to
tell you we we just call each other we
don't have uh are you free well yeah
because we're all farts that's what it
that's what we do with each other we're
all we're old we're old we text like old
people the other thing is do you use the
smile
Emoji yes me too that's a that well now
that's considered cool again for a while
it was over but now now you're back in
cuz the smile
okay there's a whole thing with the
Emojis like will you haha stuff haha
very rarely I use haha and it turns out
that's okay that's okay if you want to
be haa is stupid well if you really well
what you're supposed to do if
something's
funny you put uh the coffin Emoji cuz
it's killing you it's so funny that
means it's really funny laughing my ass
off or any right right
the Gen Z I guess which is the youngest
generation is the most anxious
generation so they may look at every
detail of a text to interpret its
meaning like if a text seems too short
or clipped without an LOL they may
interpret that as the cender being angry
or upset with them or if there's a
period at the end of the sentence they
interpret it as someone is angry with
them well I'm not texting any of them
because I don't put that much thought
into a text here is Rachel who is 16
wants to tell us
how to text like a young person go ahead
Rachel please hip us
Rachel oh
[__] hi he now hey what's up I did
hello see a lot of the young kids don't
know how to use they don't how to use a
phone yeah they don't they just laugh
cuz they're like who who would talk on
the
phone